no episódio anterior de é que nem tinha
acabado há muito tempo está sempre vivo
eu não sei o que eu sei que eu vou
encontrá-lo
o personagem é uma mulher não tem vida
música também não vamos sim 500 mil
frases julic o rg o colégio está já
matou alguém
anjos e demônios satanás demônio a
história do céu e quem é um cientista
não é real
um filme de grande sucesso quer dizer
não sair pela tangente
quem tem cabelo não saiu
[Música]
eu acho que a coisa pessoal
entrei na internet passem por lá pessoal
de cada inscrição deixar você punho eles
fazem deste tipo os top as coisas mais
bizarras das 10 coisas que vocês não
sabem sobre na urina para quem não sabe
é cheia para implementar as coisas que
vocês não sabem sobre che pobres passem
por lá
vejam informe especial vosso apoio
pessoal e vejo que meu poema estúdio
leque favorito e vai até a próxima sexta